Ivory has been producing their uniquely floating
soap for the well over a century now and in
that time they’ve become one of the most
popular soap brands in the world.
For many years, the company has maintained
that the discovery of its trademark floating
soap was a complete accident, but exactly
how true is this?
For those of you who aren’t familiar with
Ivory brand soap, in a nutshell its two key
selling points are that it is incredibly pure
(99.44% pure) and that it floats, making it
superior to all other kinds of soap because
you don’t need to grope around on the bottom
of the bath to find it.
These two traits have made Ivory soap one
of the most popular and enduring brands and
both features have been played up to by the
company itself in its advertising for almost
as long as it has existed.
If anyone is curious about why Ivory soap
floats, the soap is produced in such a way
as to ensure air is whipped into the soap
mixture before it sets; as a result, the final
product contains numerous tiny air bubbles
which work together to make the soap ever
so slightly less dense than water, allowing
it to float.
These air bubbles also serve a dual function
of making the soap produce a more consistent
and bubbly lather when used, another fact
the company has historically drawn attention
to in its advertising.
Something you can easily see for yourself
by popping a bar of Ivory into your microwave;
you know, for science.
As for how this discovery came about, for
over a century, Ivory has insisted that the
invention of floating soap was a happy accident
that occurred as a result of an unnamed employee
accidentally leaving a batch of soap mixture
to mix for too long while he was on his lunch
break.
The story continues that when the employee
returned and realised his mistake, he reasoned
that since nothing new had been added to the
mixture, there was no reason to throw out
the batch.
In some versions of the story, the employee
told his manager about the mistake, who came
to the same conclusion.
In both versions of the story, the mixture
was then sent to be set and cut into bars
at which point it was promptly forgotten about.
That was until a few weeks later when orders
began flooding in for “floating soap”
which confused the workers at Ivory who had
no idea such a product existed, let alone
that they sold it.
After receiving dozens of orders for this
mythical product, the company conducted an
internal investigation until the tainted batch
was found, at which point they came to the
realization that the extra mixing must have
added air to the mixture, making the soap
light enough to float.
While this may sound a little too convenient,
there are well documented cases of such happy
accidents happening.
For example, artificial sweetener was discovered
because a researcher ate a sandwich after
forgetting to wash his hands; Super Glue was
invented by accident, not once, but twice;
the Slinky was originally supposed to be used
as a tension spring in horsepower meters in
battleships before the inventor accidentally
knocked one off his desk… the list of famous
accidental inventions goes on and on and on.
And as Ivory has insisted that that’s how
it happened for 12 decades or so, case closed
right?
Not exactly.
Perhaps the first tip-off should have been
the “unnamed employee.”
These sorts of stories that are vague on specifics
on names and dates while overly detailed and
elaborate on the rest often tend to be false
or wildly exaggerated.
But the nail in the coffin came in 2004, when
this accidental floating soap origin story
was officially debunked.
In a strange twist, it just so happened to
be debunked by one of Ivory’s own archivists
while they were researching for a book about
the history of Proctor & Gamble Co (the company
that owns Ivory).
According to the archivist, a notebook from
1863 was found, in which a chemist working
for P&G nonchalantly noted, “I made floating
soap today.
I think we’ll make all of our stock that
way.”
But here’s the weirdest part, the chemist
who made that discovery was none other than
James Gamble, the son of the man who co-founded
the company, James Gamble Sr.
Yet, somehow, the fact that he invented one
of the company’s most famous and enduring
products was forgotten about for over a century.
Although Gamble discovered the process to
make soap float way back in 1863 and seemingly
had plans to “make all our stock that way”,
the idea was shelved for quite some time,
further demonstrating that the eventual launch
was purposeful, not accidental.
The first bar of Ivory floating soap sold
to consumers happened in 1879, advertised
from the beginning as the soap that floats.
In 1923, Ivory hired legendary PR man Edward
Bernays to advertise their brand.
After being hired, Bernays convinced them
to given thousands of free bars of soap to
schools so children could carve them into
sculptures.
As a result, soap carving became a big thing,
leading to an increase in both sales and brand
awareness.
In 2001, the company intentionally released
just over a thousand bars of their soap which
wouldn’t float and offered a share of a
$250,000 prize to anyone who could find one.
As far as we could find, none of the sinking
bars were ever turned in, presumably reflecting
the fact that most people shower these days
so wouldn’t otherwise notice unless they
made an effort to check.
Sales, nonetheless, increased by a good margin
thanks to this ad campaign.
In 1994, researchers asked a bunch of children
to taste test some soap- you know, for science-
and discovered that Ivory soap tasted the
least disgusting overall, which is something
we guess.